writing good tests can be a challenge
and writing reliable UI tests it's
substantially more difficult user
interfaces are asynchronous driven by
events transitions and data loaded from
background threads coding around that
without any help from a UI testing
framework would require a lot of
boilerplate and handling of edge cases
on the other hand say I give you a phone
with a sample app and tell you to test a
feature of the app that I just
implemented for example please make sure
that saving a new note in my note-taking
app works what would you do well I'm
pretty sure that you would look for a
Save button once you've found it you tap
on it and then check if the note is
present in the list of saved notes
that's actually a pretty good scenario
for a UI test and it's simple to
understand for a person but how would we
go about expressing it in code the
espresso framework was created
specifically for this purpose to enable
developers to write UI tests that are
concise reliable and using a fluent API
and most importantly espresso takes care
of synchronization with any UI events so
that in most cases you don't have to
worry about any viewstate transitions
and implementation details looking back
at the simple UI test we just defined we
can see that the basic flow when using
espresso is exactly the same as in our
real life scenario first find a view
using some matching rules then perform
an action on it and finally verify the
resulting state before I go any further
and start writing actual test code let's
make sure that the Android test Runner
and espresso dependencies are configured
in build.gradle I'll add the
dependencies and setup the runner here
if you're using a version of Android
studio that lets you select the test
artifact remember to switch to Android
instrumentation tests under build
variants I'm using Android studio 2.0
which has a combined view for both local
and instrumentation tests so I can
already see both in my project view
instrumentation tests go under the
Android test source set so I'll create a
sample test glass here a name it notes
screen tests
I have to add an annotation on the test
class to specify that I will be writing
Ju ins for tests and running them with
the Android J unit forerunner the notes
screen in our app is contained in the
notes activity by adding an activity
test role I'm telling the runner to
launch the activity before any tests and
turn it down after they finish all this
is taken care of with this line now I'll
add a new method with a descriptive name
for the actual test and start with the
basic structure I explained before
notice that on view is actually a method
on the espresso class but across my
testing code I will use static imports
to be able to express the tests in a
more concise way alright let's go
through the arguments next we need a
matter in order to find a view in the
current view hierarchy espresso comes
with a set of built-in matters for
common view properties like with ID with
text is checked and many others we
provide a simple cheat sheet so you
don't have to go digging through the
documentation every time in my case I
want to locate the floating action
button which fortunately is the only
item on the screen with the ID fab add
notes now that I've isolated the view
that I need using matters it's time to
apply a view action or in other words a
user interaction that will be simulated
by espresso I just want to click the fab
but again there are many more built-in
actions like typing and even finger
swipes that I can use to interact with
views and finally I verified the outcome
of my actions by using a view assertion
since I want to check if an input field
is shown on screen after pressing the
fab I'll move this block of code here
and I use the matches assertion that
accepts a view matter so to summarize
what we have so far the first statement
matches a floating action button and
clicks it which should bring up the add
note screen the second statement finds
the edit text that lets a user enter a
note title and verifies that it is
displayed using the matches view
assertion notice that I didn't have to
write any code in between to wait for
previous events to finish as espresso
already takes care of that for me
to run the test I right-click on the
test class and select run because it's
an instrumentation test
it requires an emulator or physical
device I can see the actions on the
screen as they execute
here's a slightly longer test that
includes typing into the ED notes screen
and saving a note all using espresso
unless you're writing end-to-end tests
you should keep your test small and
scoped which will make them more
reliable if you want to practice adding
and running UI tests on your own I
suggest you check out our Android
testing code lab which I based this
video on it contains a downloadable
project and step-by-step instructions to
get you started
join me for the next episode of Android
testing patterns to learn how to handle
adapter views in your tests good luck
and happy testing
you